did you ever confront each other and
kind of make it cool was there ever a
moment where like I can't I can't work
with them I'm not going on stage I'm not
doing this kind of wrap that up you know
it's like
look I've been working since I was a kid
and I've been working in really high
pressure adults you know how to deal
with it
but I'd never gone first of all reality
TV live live was a brand new thing so
it's it's an it's awkward it's
intimidating you don't know I had to
learn oh my God if we're typing in front
of live audience they can alter and edit
my words to not eat I I'll never forget
having Entertainment Tonight in my house
in the living room with my family and I
can't wait because I work for
Entertainment Tonight I'm going guys
wait till you hear
what Simon Says and how I defend this
amazing girl
I I had I was saying like this is the
most insane statement you could ever
make that all you have to say is your
look like a fat version of Jessica
Simpson how can you say that she said
that he said that yes oh yes and that
was cut and all of that's cut and this
is what you see you're so pretty